hello ladies and gentlemen i'm ryan
right I'm five for brown five for brown
here
movie star of the gallows that's right
people we get celebrities on here we're
gonna watch the trailer for finding dory
I'm really looking forward to this
I love Finding Nemo me to cry like a
little [ __ ] every time every time
who do you relate to I relate to dory so
I'm excited for this I have a short-term
memory and I'm a LESBIAN I'm pretty
excited is the in Pixar don't let me
monetize by the way
yeah this is just pretty good
[Music]
don't cry mommy don't cry
[Music]
she's talking in her sleep I can fix it
yeah why did she start sleep swimming
again I'm sure this was a one-time thing
so can we just all go back to I
remembered something that's not possible
is it okay is it like a picture in your
head and then you think I've seen this
before
I just use the word before which means
I'm remembering something what was I
talking about
[Music]
something important what
something about a clan or no an oyster
no mollusk something I don't know how
that's the first one yeah I was I was
just enjoy because it was like I haven't
seen it in years
and I I forgot how beautiful this world
is and the kindda charm and style oh my
god because I remember it being so
illustrative like oh wow they really
brought the ocean to life you know
beautiful Oh Endora was my favorite
character in Finding Nemo I remember I
used to like one I was like I want to
have like a personality like Dory Dory
stole the show yeah Daugherty was
[ __ ] hilarious like all the voice
actors are great but everyone when you
asked he was really funny everyone would
say door it was dory
so it's interesting to see how they're
taking a side character and now making
that one the main focus should be
forgetting everything throughout the
entire thing I don't know I mean it's
probably gonna be uncovering more and
more and more it sounds like she was
saying mommy at the beginning so it
sounds like she had a traumatizing past
she kind of blocked it out yeah that's
what it seems oh my gosh because they do
it seems all fun and games inside out
really explored psychology of the mind
and so I figure only why don't they deal
with the fish yeah exactly
oh I'm pond hour Dory and and Nemo's dad
that's a great question
they just seem eight what's the what's
new Mo's dad's name again Oh God oh
here's a happy name just dad no yes he
has a name it's like coral or something
oh it is something like that clown
there's a movie database available
tomorrow
Merle Merle Marlon
something like that Marlin anyway I had
a point about Marlin that I can okay
yeah you were talking about Marlin if
he's sleeping with Dori you know that
would be a perfect relationship for a
guy because if he like has feelings for
Dorian wants to bone that fish but he
wants to bone other fish Dori will just
forget about their relationship every
time imagine 50 first dates remember
when Adam Sandler you know he's like he
keeps repeating like give catching her
up every day imagine instead of catching
her up every day and sounder one day
decides I want to sleep with someone
else I ain't gonna catch up drew
Barrymore on the day that is the
advantage Marlin has in this movie Oh
Marley oh my kids trailer appropriate
jokes cool cool
and I like how it's called finding dory
but it's not the same plot it's like
Dory is trying to find herself and
remember her past oh that's kind of what
so yeah her loss yeah she's not you mean
she's lost internalized their heart
what's her story it's a great title with
a great story to it as I was like okay
make sense story as amnesia she's gonna
get lost right then you watch the
trailer like oh it's not about her
getting lost they're actually going on
this adventure together and to find
yourself that's cool I like that Ellen's
the perfect voice for dory Ellen is the
perfect person Dory alright yeah yeah
finding Dory finding the words there
I'll be there anyway guys thanks for
tuning into the channel if you're new to
it you can click this button above my
head and subscribe to the real rejects
to become a reject abut Pfeiffer you can
follow her on Facebook Instagram Twitter
follow her that way you can be caught up
on her life and her
Nicholas Reynoso hard times does keep
finding their way into my life and
tearing everything apart
although friends are lost and others
have died I still can't seem to find a
smile on my face when I watch your
YouTube channel also if you remember I'm
the guy who asked for a guest appearance
and asked if your girlfriend poops
rainbows thanks Ryan
and can I get a shout-out I do remember
you Nicholas you did ask about my
girlfriend pooping rainbows and actually
she poops a little tiny starfish most
adorable thing some horrible thing bless
her heart this started off really
depressing honestly if we're the only
thing making you smile right now that's
a serious issue I would recommend
therapy that way you could talk with
someone because if this is all real you
have to start solving it from going deep
in the inside prayer prayer helps too
I've already come down as spiritual
mental physical intellectual financial
mm-hmm and relational developing
friendships you can't do it on your own
three jobs people thanks for reaching
out to to us and reach around to people
that's a yeah yeah that's a maneuver a
sex maneuver and reaching around you do
a reach around this comes back to sex
with you know I have a hard time
maintaining sincerity and honesty it's
okay I always resort to sometimes joke
in the end all and that's his problem
that we're working on right now with all
that issues I have so much trauma that I
get my defense mechanisms up and I eat
block it with humor sometimes I can't
tell if you're being serious right now
do you want me to be serious I mean I
want you to be transparent and share
your heart with me but I don't reach
around cuz reach around she said it so
you were kidding